I had a weird conversation with a congressman this week. This is Mark Pocan, Democrat out of Wisconsin. The main sponsor of a bill to do this thing that protesters have been calling for the last few months, abolish ICE, the Immigration and Customs Enforcement agency. His bill would terminate the agency. Immigration enforcement would continue, but a bipartisan commission would hand off the stuff that ICE does to other federal agencies, and eliminate anything it deems inhumane or cruel, or a violation of international agreements. After one year, the agency would not exist. It would be abolished. But the politics of this are so peculiar that in our half hour conversation, the congressman could not bring himself to say the actual words that he would abolish ICE.
这周我和一位国会议员进行了一次奇怪的谈话。这位议员是来自威斯康星州的民主党人马克·波坎（Mark Pocan）。他是众议院一项法案的主要发起人，该法案旨在实现抗议者过去几个月一直在呼吁的目标：废除美国移民与海关执法局（ICE）。他的法案将终止该机构。移民执法工作将继续进行，但一个两党委员会将把ICE负责的事务移交给其他联邦机构，并取消任何被认为不人道、残酷或违反国际协议的职能。一年后，该机构将不复存在。它将被废除。但这背后的政治博弈极其古怪，以至于在我们半小时的谈话中，这位议员始终无法说出“我会废除ICE”这样的话。
Do you want to abolish the agency?
你想废除这个机构吗？
I think I've answered that question a few times, Ira.
艾拉，我想这个问题我已经回答过几次了。
But just yes or no. Do you want to abolish the agency?
但请只回答是或否。你想废除这个机构吗？
Ira, for a half hour, I've given you a conversation on this, and I think I've explained what I'm trying to do. Do you have the bill, because do you need me to shoot you the words. I'm not sure if you have it in front of you.
艾拉，我已经就这个问题和你谈了半个小时了，我想我已经解释了我想做的事情。你有那份法案吗？如果你需要我把文字念给你听的话。我不确定你是否把它放在面前。
No, I have it in front of me. It says to establish a commission that would terminate Immigration and Customs Enforcement.
不，我有。上面写着成立一个委员会，终止移民与海关执法局。
It's establish a commission to reassign the essential duties that were created by ICE to other agencies, and to get rid of the unnecessary duties. That's the essential thrust of the bill, and that's what we're trying to accomplish.
是成立一个委员会，将ICE创造的必要职责重新分配给其他机构，并剔除不必要的职责。这就是该法案的核心目的，也是我们试图实现的。
Right. So you do want to terminate the agency? You do want to abolish the agency?
对。所以你确实想终止这个机构？你确实想废除它？
I want to make sure the essential duties of the agency--
我想确保该机构的基本职责——
To understand why he was talking this way, let me tell you the story of his last two weeks in Congress. It began when he proposed this bill to abolish ICE. Mainly, he and his co-sponsors were objecting to the way that President Trump has the agency going after undocumented immigrants these days. One of his co-sponsors, Congresswoman Pramila Jayapal told me they had no illusions about this ever making it to the floor of the House.
为了理解他为什么要这样说话，让我告诉你们他过去两周在国会的经历。这一切始于他提出废除ICE的法案。主要是因为他和联合发起人们反对特朗普总统目前利用该机构针对无证移民的方式。其中一位联合发起人，普拉米拉·贾亚帕尔（Pramila Jayapal）众议员告诉我，他们对这项法案能被提交到众议院表决不抱任何幻想。
No, no, no. Because no immigration bills on our side get brought to the floor, not even ones that have significant co-sponsorship, including Republican co-sponsorship, like the Dream Act. And so it was very clear to us that this was just a messaging bill for us to be able to really talk about how outrageous the agency is.
不，不，不。因为我们这边的移民法案根本不会被提交表决，即使是那些有重要共同发起人，包括共和党共同发起人的法案，比如《梦想法案》（Dream Act），也不会被提交。所以对我们来说很清楚，这只是一项用来传达信息的法案，让我们能够真正讨论这个机构是多么令人愤慨。
So they introduced their bill, and it got some Democratic support. But you know who really loved it? Republicans.
于是他们提出了法案，并得到了一些民主党人的支持。但你知道谁最喜欢它吗？共和党人。
They have really jumped the sharks on the left.
左派真的已经走火入魔了。
This is the Speaker of the House, Paul Ryan.
这是众议院议长保罗·瑞安（Paul Ryan）。
They have really-- it's an amazing, it's the craziest position I've ever seen. And they are just tripping over themselves to move too far to the left. They're out of the mainstream of America.
他们真的——这是我见过最疯狂的立场。他们只是急于表现得过于左倾。他们已经脱离了美国的主流。
For months now, actually, conservative media have loved any hint that the Democrats want to abolish ICE. Fits into their whole narrative that the Democrats are soft on immigration, and adds a kind of wingnut extremist edge to it, like people who call for the abolition of the Internal Revenue Service. In that way, abolish ICE is the build the wall of the left, blunt like a punch to the jaw, exciting for those who believe in it, whackadoodle for those who don't. And if you get right down to it, maybe not the very best way to fix the problem that it is supposed to fix, but that is not what we're here talking about today.
几个月来，保守派媒体一直乐于捕捉任何关于民主党想要废除ICE的暗示。这符合他们关于民主党对移民问题立场软弱的叙事，并给它增加了一种极端主义色彩，就像那些呼吁废除美国国税局的人一样。从这个意义上说，“废除ICE”就像左派的“修建隔离墙”，像重拳一样直白，对那些信仰它的人来说很刺激，对不信的人来说则很疯狂。如果深究起来，这也许并不是解决问题的最好办法，但这并不是我们今天讨论的主题。
Here are Jesse Watters and Laura Ingraham, gleeful on Fox.
这是福克斯新闻的杰西·沃特斯（Jesse Watters）和劳拉·英格拉汉姆（Laura Ingraham），他们幸灾乐祸。
I cannot believe they're doing it. It's political suicide.
我无法相信他们竟然这么做。这是政治自杀。
Good luck on turning that into a platform that actually wins votes.
祝他们能把这个变成一个真正能赢得选票的纲领。
President Trump tweeted, "The two biggest opponents of ICE in America today are  the Democratic Party  and MS-13!"
特朗普总统发推文说：“今天美国ICE最大的两个反对者是民主党和MS-13帮派！”
I love that issue if they're going to actually do that. They're seriously talking about that?
如果他们真要这么做，我太喜欢这个议题了。他们是认真的吗？
It didn't take long, just one day. The Republican leadership in the House was like, you want to abolish ICE? Great. Here's House Majority Leader, Kevin McCarthy.
没花多长时间，仅仅一天。众议院共和党领导层就像是说，你们想废除ICE？太好了。这是众议院多数党领袖凯文·麦卡锡（Kevin McCarthy）。
Well, you know what? We're going to have a vote on the floor.
好吧，你知道吗？我们要进行投票。
So Mark Pocan and a few of his co-sponsors did something you do not see very often. They told everybody, we have this bill, don't vote for it. Basically, it's a trap.
所以马克·波坎和他的几位共同发起人做了一件你很少见到的事情。他们告诉所有人：我们有这个法案，但别投票支持它。基本上，这是一个陷阱。
Clearly, there was no real intention to see that bill pass. They were trying to use it as some kind of a gotcha at election time.
很明显，他们并没有真正打算让法案通过。他们只是想在选举时用它作为一个陷阱。
Apparently, the Republicans saw this, that all the Democrats were ready to go on record and vote, all of them together, and say they do not want to abolish ICE, which is exactly the opposite message that the Republicans want them to be carrying into midterms. So they ditched that plan. The bill didn't come to the fore. Instead, this week, Republicans in the House took a different tack.
显然，共和党人看穿了这一点，他们发现所有民主党人都准备好投票表态，所有人一起站出来说他们不想废除ICE，这与共和党希望他们在中期选举中传达的信息正好相反。所以他们放弃了那个计划。该法案没有被提交表决。相反，本周，众议院的共和党人采取了不同的策略。
The clerk will report the title of the resolution.
书记官将宣读决议标题。
House resolution 990, resolution supporting the officers and personnel who carry out the important mission of the United States Immigration and Customs Enforcement.
众议院第990号决议案，支持执行美国移民与海关执法局重要使命的官员和人员。
Behold, a House resolution in support of ICE and also incidentally officially denouncing anybody who calls for the agency's abolishment. Calls to abolish ICE, it says, are an insult to these heroic law enforcement officers who make sacrifices every day to secure our borders, enforce our laws, and protect our safety and security. No surprise it passed easily, 244 to 35. Most Democrats, 133 of them, simply voted present, and thus avoided being on the record either for or against the agency. That is just how radioactive, how politically dangerous this whole idea of abolishing ICE is. The phrase, abolish ICE, does not even appear in the Democrats' bill to abolish ICE.
看，这是一项支持ICE的众议院决议，顺便正式谴责任何呼吁废除该机构的人。决议称，废除ICE的呼声是对这些英勇的执法人员的侮辱，他们每天为了保卫边境、执行法律以及保护我们的安全而做出牺牲。毫无意外，该决议以244票对35票轻松通过。大多数民主党人，共133人，仅仅投了“出席”票，从而避免了在是否支持该机构的问题上留下记录。这就是“废除ICE”这个想法在政治上有多么危险和敏感。“废除ICE”这个词组甚至没有出现在民主党人废除ICE的法案中。
And I suppose that's why Congressman Pocan did not want to say the phrase out loud with me. Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, we have two stories from this hot potato of a federal agency, one that does so many things I bet you know nothing about, one that has expanded its powers rapidly. Stay with us.
我想这就是为什么波坎议员不想和我当面说出这个词组的原因。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》（This American Life），我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天在我们的节目中，我们有两个关于这个烫手联邦机构的故事，它做的事情多到我敢说你一无所知，而且它的权力在迅速扩张。请继续收听。
Act One, We'll Talk About It in the Car.
第一幕，我们在车里谈谈。
So in this show about ICE, before we get started, it seems like it might be a good idea to do a very quick primer on what exactly ICE is. The agency has only been around for 15 years. It was created after September 11th. The idea was, Customs and Border Protection would be the agency at the actual border stopping people there. ICE would deal with the interior of the country, and a lot of its mission at the beginning was very post-9/11. It was all about catching terrorists, arms traffickers, cyber crimes, transnational gangs, child predators, catching criminals of various sorts.
关于这个关于ICE的节目，在开始之前，先简单科普一下ICE到底是什么似乎是个好主意。该机构成立才15年。它是在“9·11”事件后成立的。最初的想法是，海关及边境保卫局（CBP）负责在边境拦截人员，而ICE则负责处理美国国内事务。起初它的许多使命都是针对“9·11”后的情况，全是关于打击恐怖分子、军火贩运者、网络犯罪、跨国帮派、虐童分子，抓捕各种罪犯。
One department of ICE went after undocumented immigrants. But it was not nearly as robust. It did not do as much until after immigration reform failed in 2007. Since then, that part of the agency has stepped up its game under rules set by each new administration. President Obama still has the record for the most people deported, but President Trump, of course, has unleashed agents like they have never been unleashed before. Today, they can question pretty much anybody they meet and put them into deportation proceedings, even if they have no criminal record, even if they have lived here productively and peacefully for decades.
ICE的一个部门负责打击无证移民。但它远没有那么强硬。在2007年移民改革失败之前，它并没有做那么多工作。从那时起，在每一届新政府制定的规则下，该机构的那部分职能一直在加强。奥巴马总统仍然保持着驱逐出境人数最多的纪录，但特朗普总统当然已经像从未有过的程度那样“释放”了这些特工。今天，他们几乎可以盘问遇到的任何人，并将他们送入驱逐程序，即使他们没有犯罪记录，即使他们已经在生产、平静地生活了几十年。
ICE has brought back worksite raids. They're involved with the family separations, along with Customs and Border Protection. This week, there were, and of course it's a unique week, because every day, families that the Trump administration separated at the border are being reunited. The administration has a court imposed deadline to get everybody back together by Thursday, July 26. That's why they acknowledged that they are not going to make it, or maybe even come close, which brings us to our first story today. And OK, I realize there is a lot of coverage out there of parents being reunited with children.
ICE恢复了工地突袭行动。他们与海关及边境保卫局一起参与了家庭分离。本周，当然这是非常特殊的一周，因为每天都有被特朗普政府在边境拆散的家庭正在团聚。政府设定了7月26日星期四的法院强制期限，要求让所有人团聚。这就是为什么他们承认他们无法完成任务，甚至连接近目标都做不到，这引出了我们今天的第一段故事。好的，我知道关于父母与孩子团聚的报道很多。
But we came across this audio that we thought was unusual, and took us inside the world of that in this way that we had not heard elsewhere. A reporter named Jeremy Raff, who's with The Atlantic, has been following this one lawyer in Texas for this documentary he's making. And he's friends with one of the producers of our show, Nadia Reiman and shared with her this material that he's been videotaping of this lawyer trying to reunite one mom and her son. Quick warning that we've unbeeped the curse words here in the podcast. If you prefer a beeped version of our show, maybe you're listening with kids, it's at our website. Here's Nadia and you will hear from Jeremy, the reporter, later in the story.
但我们偶然发现了一段录音，我们认为它很特别，带我们进入了那个世界，这是我们在别处从未听说过的。一位名叫杰里米·拉夫（Jeremy Raff）的《大西洋月刊》记者一直在跟踪报道德克萨斯州的一位律师，为他正在制作的纪录片做准备。他和我们节目的制作人之一纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）是朋友，并将他拍摄的这位律师试图让一位母亲和她儿子团聚的视频资料分享给了她。提前警告一下，我们在播客中没有对脏话进行消音处理。如果你喜欢消音版，或者你是和孩子们一起听，请访问我们的网站。这是纳迪亚，稍后你会在故事中听到记者杰里米的讲述。
Jodi Goodwin, the immigration lawyer, speaks pretty good Spanish for a white girl. She's effortless in it, moves through her words in neatly accented Norteno tones, dropping perfectly placed Spanish f-bombs.
移民律师乔迪·古德温（Jodi Goodwin）对一个白人女孩来说，西班牙语说得非常好。她说得毫不费力，用带有些许北方口音的语调流畅地表达，还会穿插恰到好处的西班牙语脏话。
[SPEAKING SPANISH] dialing numbers, you know, just waiting for somebody to answer the phone. How are you doing?
[西班牙语] 正在拨号，你知道，只是等着有人接电话。你怎么样？
That's her on the phone with an ICE officer. She's in Harlingen, Texas, way down in the southern tip, where she's been practicing immigration law for more than 20 years. So she knows these guys. She's grown up with them.
那是她正在和一位ICE官员通电话。她位于德克萨斯州的哈灵根，地处最南端，她在那里从事移民法律工作已经超过20年了。所以她认识这些人。她是和他们一起成长的。
I mean I care about them. I mean, they're my friends. They're people that I work with all the time. I mean, we've known each other for like over two decades. We've seen our kids be born, we've gone through health issues with our children. The kids go to the same schools.
我是说，我在乎他们。我的意思是，他们是我的朋友。他们是我一直共事的人。我们认识都超过二十年了。我们看着彼此的孩子出生，我们一起经历了孩子们的健康问题。孩子们上同一所学校。
Yeah, yeah, I'm here.
对，对，我在这儿。
She's on the phone trying to get a Honduran woman named Anita out of detention and reunited with her son, Jenri. They have been separated for about a month. An ICE agent told her that Anita should be out on bond, but she's not.
她正在打电话试图让一位名叫安妮塔（Anita）的洪都拉斯妇女从拘留中心获释，并与她的儿子詹里（Jenri）团聚。他们已经分离大约一个月了。一位ICE探员告诉她，安妮塔应该获准保释，但她并没有出来。
Are you freaking kidding me? I know. This woman has a freaking five year old. OK, who's my best bet with the supervisors to get this overridden? Because this is bullshit to have one policy for some people and continue to cause prolonged trauma to a fucking five year old.
你在开玩笑吗？我知道。这个女人有个五岁的孩子。好了，我找哪个主管能推翻这个决定？因为对一些人实行一种政策，却继续对一个该死的五岁孩子造成长期创伤，这简直是胡扯。
Even the ICE agents that Jodi's known for over two decades have conflicting info. One says, yeah, she should be out soon on bond. The other is like, no, we're not giving bonds anymore. But Jodi talks to a manager, and she gets them to release Anita. Anita's kid, Jenri, though, he's at a shelter nearby. It's called BCFS. To get him out, Jodi has his birth certificate and Anita's ID. She's emailed all the necessary paperwork, but she's still not sure how it will play out.
即使是乔迪认识了二十多年的ICE探员，也提供相互矛盾的信息。一个说，是的，她很快就能保释。另一个说，不，我们不再提供保释了。但乔迪和一位经理谈了谈，她让他们释放了安妮塔。不过，安妮塔的孩子詹里还在附近的一家收容所里。它叫BCFS。为了接他出来，乔迪带了他的出生证明和安妮塔的身份证。她通过电子邮件发送了所有必要的文件，但她仍然不确定结果会怎样。
She's seen other parents do this, and be told, you can visit for an hour, but you can't have your child back. Come back again tomorrow. One parent had been told this four times. Four days in a row, they showed up, hung out with their kid for an hour, and still, no reunification. So recently, some parents have been buying tents and threatening to set up a camp right outside the shelters, refusing to leave until they get their kids back. So Jodi tells Anita about this and says, do you want to sleep outside if that's what it takes to get Jenri back?
她见过其他父母这样做，结果却被告知：你可以探视一小时，但不能把孩子领回去。明天再来。有一位家长被告知过四次。连续四天，他们出现并和孩子待了一个小时，结果仍然没有团聚。所以最近，一些父母开始买帐篷，威胁要在收容所外扎营，拒绝离开，直到找回孩子。所以乔迪告诉安妮塔这些情况，问道：如果必须睡在外面才能接回詹里，你愿意吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Si.
是的。
Anita's like, yes. While Jodi is explaining all of this to Anita, she's going through this huge stack of papers. She turns one page, and there is a black and white photo of Anita and her son. It was taken just a few moments before border patrol separated them. Anita sees this picture, and starts to tear up. Jodi notices.
安妮塔说，愿意。当乔迪向安妮塔解释这一切时，她正在翻阅一大叠文件。她翻过一页，上面有一张安妮塔和儿子的黑白照片。那是边境巡逻队将他们分开前几分钟拍的。安妮塔看到这张照片，开始流泪。乔迪注意到了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
And she's like, hey, we're in this fight together.
她像是说，嘿，我们是一起在战斗。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Those tears, we're going to save those tears for when you get your kid back.
那些眼泪，我们要把它们留到你找回孩子的时候再流。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
The mama bear is going to come out. We're going to be a mama bear tomorrow. So the next morning, they drive to the shelter armed with paperwork. It looks like a church. There are basketball courts outside, there's classrooms. Jodi and Anita knock on the door, and they go inside. And then, some BCFS employees take them to this room, and there's Jenri. No need for tents or mama bears or anything. They're ready to release them. Anita's thrilled, but her five year old, who hasn't seen her in a month--
母狮要出动了。我们明天要变成母狮。第二天早上，她们拿着文件前往收容所。它看起来像一座教堂。外面有篮球场，有教室。乔迪和安妮塔敲开门，走了进去。然后，一些BCFS的员工带她们进了一个房间，詹里就在那里。不需要帐篷或母狮之类的东西。他们准备释放他们了。安妮塔很激动，但她那一个月没见到她的五岁孩子——
Jenri was sitting in a chair, and he remained seated in the chair. And he didn't get out of the chair. He didn't run to his mom. And that shocked Anita. She started crying, and she knelt down on the floor in front of the chair where her little boy was sitting. And she tried to give him a hug, and she asked for forgiveness a lot of times. [SPEAKING SPANISH] over and over again. And then she kept talking to him and she pulled herself back a little bit so she could see his face.
詹里坐在椅子上，他保持着坐姿。他没有从椅子上下来。他没有跑向他妈妈。这让安妮塔震惊了。她开始哭泣，并在那个小男孩坐的椅子前跪在地上。她试着拥抱他，并多次请求原谅。[西班牙语] 一遍又一遍。然后她继续对他说话，她稍微后退了一点，这样她就能看到他的脸。
She put her hands on his face, and she asked how he was and if they had treated him well. And he didn't say anything. She kind of just gave it a few seconds to make some eye contact. It was probably about a minute later that he reached his arms around and gave her a big hug, and I think they probably hugged each other for about two minutes before they let go.
她把双手放在他的脸上，问他怎么样，他们对他好不好。他什么也没说。她给了他几秒钟做眼神接触。可能大约一分钟后，他伸出双臂给了她一个大大的拥抱，我想他们大概拥抱了两分钟才分开。
It's not clear why it was so quick to get him out. Jodi's best guess is that it's some combination of all the media attention plus the upcoming deadline for reunifying parents and kids. On top of that, if Anita had set up a tent outside, which she was totally ready to do, it wouldn't have been great press.
为什么能这么快接他出来还不清楚。乔迪的最佳猜测是媒体关注加上即将到来的父母与孩子团聚期限的共同作用。最重要的是，如果安妮塔在外面扎了帐篷，而她完全准备好这样做，那将不是什么好的新闻报道。
So all this audio was gathered by my friend, Jeremy Raff, from The Atlantic, and I'm just going to let him mostly take it from here. When Jodi and Anita went to pick up Jenri, he was there, but he wasn't allowed in the shelter. So he waited outside. It was like 100 degrees out, so he was under a tree.
所以所有这些录音都是我的朋友，来自《大西洋月刊》的杰里米·拉夫收集的，接下来大部分时间就让他来讲吧。当乔迪和安妮塔去接詹里时，他在那里，但他不能进收容所。所以他在外面等着。当时大约有100华氏度（约38摄氏度），所以他待在一棵树下。
After a long time, I see, first I catch sight of Jodi, and she's walking next to a woman in a sort of starched blue button up with the BCFS logo on it. And then next to her is a really little boy, like smaller than I thought he was going to look like, holding Anita's hand. And the four of them are walking out.
过了很长时间，我先看到了乔迪，她正走在一个穿着浆洗过的蓝色扣领衬衫、上面印有BCFS标志的女人旁边。在她旁边是一个很小的男孩，看起来比我预想的还要小，牵着安妮塔的手。他们四个人一起走了出来。
I've seen a bunch of videos and photos online of parents being reunited with their kids, grabbing them like a life raft while the kid looks confused and far away. But they usually stop here. I'd never really heard what happens next, once the parents and kids are left trying to figure out how to be with each other again after weeks of not knowing where the other slept or ate, or when they were coming back. Jeremy is with Anita and Jenri while all of this is happening.
我在网上看过很多父母与孩子团聚的视频和照片，父母像抓住救生圈一样抱住孩子，而孩子看起来困惑且疏离。但通常视频到这就结束了。我从没真正听过接下来会发生什么，当父母和孩子在经历了数周不知道对方在哪里睡觉或吃饭，或者不知道对方什么时候回来之后，又要努力重新学会如何在一起生活。这一切发生时，杰里米正和安妮塔与詹里在一起。
They walk up to Jodi's truck and they open the door, and like, you know, Jodi has a kid the same age as this little boy, and so she brought some of his toys along and they're in the back seat. And so he's like checking out these little monster trucks that Jodi brought for him.
他们走到乔迪的卡车旁，打开车门，你知道，乔迪有一个和这个小男孩一样大的孩子，所以她带了一些他的玩具放在后座。所以他正在查看乔迪为他带来的这些小怪物卡车。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
He's saying, toys, toys.
他说，玩具，玩具。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
She's like, we're here, we came for you, are you excited? And he's sort of like information overload at this point.
她说，我们在这儿，我们来接你了，你兴奋吗？此时此刻他的信息量过载了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
He's telling her that he brought her water. He's saying, mommy, I brought you water for you to drink too.
他在告诉她，他给她带了水。他说，妈妈，我给你也带了水喝。
Yeah, he brought his mom little gifts. He brought her water. He brought her a little bracelet he was really proud of that he gave her as a gift. And then he had a little watch on that he was super proud of all day, a little Superman watch that lights up with like, you know, blinking. He's like trying to put this little watch on his mom's wrist. We stopped by this gas station, and Jodi kind of buys Jenri some treats, I think trying to make him feel like a regular kid again.
是啊，他给他妈妈带了小礼物。他带了水。他带了一个他非常引以为豪的小手镯，作为礼物送给了她。然后他整天都戴着一块他超级自豪的小手表，一块会闪烁的小超人手表，带灯的那种。他试着把这块小手表戴到他妈妈的手腕上。我们在加油站停了一下，乔迪给詹里买了一些零食，我想这是想让他感觉像个普通孩子一样。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I'm crammed in the backseat with Anita and Jenri in the car seat. He's got a little car seat for little kids. And Anita just turns to him and starts asking him all about what happened after they were separated.
我被挤在后座和安妮塔以及坐在儿童座椅里的詹里一起。他有一个适合小孩子的安全座椅。安妮塔转过身，开始问他关于他们被分开后发生的一切。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
So Anita's asking him like, where did they go, where did they take Jenri after they were separated. And Jenri's telling her her
安妮塔问他去了哪里，分开后他们把他带到了哪里。詹里在告诉她——
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[说话声重叠]
--icebox, you know you sleep on a little mattress on the ground with a space blanket.
——冰柜（icebox），你知道，你睡在地上的一张小床垫上，盖着空间毯。
So Anita's asking him if there were lots of kids with him, and he says that he was cold, and so he turns and he says to someone, teacher, I'm cold, can I have a blanket. And that person, who I'm guessing is probably like an ICE officer or something, or a--
安妮塔问他是否有许多孩子和他在一起，他说他很冷，所以他转过身对某个人说，老师，我很冷，能给我一条毯子吗。而那个人，我猜可能是ICE官员或者什么人，或者——
Border patrol agent.
边境巡逻探员。
Someone there tells them, no, not yet. And then when they finally give him a blanket, Jenri's saying that he shared it with another kid. And his mom is like you shared it with another child. And he says, yep. And she says, that's really good, sweetie.
那里的人告诉他们，不，还不行。当他们终于给他毯子时，詹里说他把它和另一个孩子分享了。他妈妈说，你把它和另一个孩子分享了？他说，是的。她说，那真的很好，亲爱的。
Yeah, I mean, this is her first time seeing him, and I think she's just looking at him, trying to imagine what he's been through while she has not been able to be there with him.
是啊，我的意思是，这是她第一次见到他，我想她只是看着他，试图想象他经历了什么，而她却没能和他在一起。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Anita's struggling, But Jenri seemed like he was doing just fine. He had chocolate. He was surrounded by toys. The next step was for them to get on a plane to go stay with a relative in another part of the US, while their asylum case was being processed. But it's a small town. There aren't a lot of flights. So they go to a shelter run by Catholic charity, where they can spend the night. When they get there, Jenri is taking in every bit of his mom's attention like a sponge.
安妮塔很挣扎，但詹里看起来好多了。他有巧克力。他被玩具包围着。下一步是他们登上一架飞机，去美国其他地方的一位亲戚家住，同时处理他们的庇护申请。但那是一个小镇。航班不多。所以他们去了一家由天主教会经营的收容所，在那里可以过夜。当他们到达时，詹里像海绵一样吸收着妈妈所有的注意力。
They're like in a little dorm room at this shelter, and they're just sort of reacclimating. They're like in a bunk bed, just, she's tickling Jenri, they're talking. They're sort of like reacquainting themselves.
他们在收容所的一个小宿舍里，他们正在重新适应。他们在一个双层床上，她正在逗詹里笑，他们在说话。他们像是正在重新认识彼此。
So there's this thing that happens. In Spanish, there's two ways of saying, I love you. There's te quiero, which means, I little love you. Like, I love you, but it's for things that are not necessarily permanent. And then there's te amo, which is like, I love you, love you, for like, I love you with a capital L, and that's for things that don't ever go away. And you do not throw a te amo around, but you can say like, te quiero, like a little bit is here.
有件事很有意思。在西班牙语里，说“我爱你”有两种方式。一种是“te quiero”，意思是“浅浅地爱你”。就像我爱你，但它适用于不一定永久的事物。然后是“te amo”，就像“我深爱你”，带着大写的“L”，用于永不磨灭的情感。你不能随便乱用“te amo”，但你可以说“te quiero”，就像有一点儿在这里。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
And so Anita is telling Jenri, she's like, guess what. And he's like, te quiero. And she's like, no, te amo. So she's like no, I really love you.
安妮塔在告诉詹里，她说，你猜怎么着。他说，te quiero。她说，不，te amo。所以她是在说不，我真的很爱你。
And he kind of giggles and he's like, te queiro, like, I little love you.
他咯咯地笑着说，te queiro，就像“浅浅地爱你”。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
That went on late into the evening. But then, around 11:00 PM, things took a bit of a turn. Jenri was still really excited and wasn't going to sleep anytime soon. And one of the nuns came in to kind of settle everyone down, make sure they had everything they needed, you know, for the next day, leaving. And Jenri's like running all over the place, right, in this little room. And he eventually reaches for the TV, almost like he's going to rip the TV off the wall, so this nun says, oh, don't touch that, you know.
这一直持续到深夜。但在晚上11点左右，事情发生了一点转折。詹里仍然非常兴奋，短时间内根本睡不着。其中一位修女进来想让大家安静下来，确保他们有第二天离开所需的一切。詹里在这个小房间里到处乱跑。他最终伸手去够电视机，好像要把电视机从墙上扯下来一样，所以这位修女说，噢，别碰那个。
At the shelter, it was actually sisters, not nuns.
其实在收容所里，是修女（sisters），不是尼姑。
And he just starts repeating, don't touch, no touching. No touching, no touching, over and over again.
他开始不停地重复，“别碰，别碰。别碰，别碰”，一遍又一遍。
No touch, no touch, no touch! No touch!
别碰，别碰，别碰！别碰！
OK, I think it's time [INAUDIBLE] so we can take him out of here.
好了，我想该[听不清]了，这样我们就能把他带出去了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH] [CRYING]
[西班牙语] [哭泣]
No touch, no touch, no touch. And you know, while he was saying that, I said, hey, where'd you learn how to say that in English, you know, because he doesn't speak English. And he said, over there where I was, in the shelter.
别碰，别碰，别碰。你知道，当他这么说的时候，我说，嘿，你在哪儿学会用英语这么说的？因为他不会说英语。他说，在他们把我关进去的地方，收容所里。
We don't actually know a lot of details about what happened to Jenri at BCFS, but that's one of the rules some of the shelters have. You can't touch other kids. The sister told Jeremy she thought Jenri was afraid he was going to be taken away from his mom again.
我们并不真正了解詹里在BCFS发生了什么细节，但那是某些收容所的规定之一。你不准碰其他孩子。那位修女告诉杰里米，她认为詹里是害怕自己会被再次从妈妈身边带走。
And then after things calmed down, about an hour later, I spoke with Anita, and I ran, you know, what I saw by her, and she told me that that's exactly what she thought happened too.
事情平息大约一小时后，我和安妮塔谈过，我告诉她我所看到的，她说那正是她认为发生的事情。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Anita says, Jenri told her, I am not your son anymore. He said that he didn't want to sleep there. He said the lady, the sister, was a bad lady too.
安妮塔说，詹里告诉她，我不再是你的儿子了。他说他不想睡在那里。他说那位女士，那位修女，也是个坏女人。
The next morning, I met them at the shelter, and Jenri was fine again. I mean, they said bye to everyone. He hugged that nun, that same nun that scared him so much. He was back to being a regular kid, and Jodi drove them to the airport. And it was both of their first time on an airplane, and when we got up into the air, they were looking out the window from the plane, and Anita's telling Jenri, see the river down there, remember when we crossed the river. Remember that. And look down there, that's where mom was in the detention center. And they were leaving that behind for the moment.
第二天早上，我在收容所见到了他们，詹里又恢复正常了。我的意思是，他们和每个人告别。他拥抱了那位修女，就是那个让他感到非常害怕的修女。他又变回了一个普通的孩子，乔迪开车送他们去了机场。这是他们两个第一次坐飞机，当我们升空时，他们从飞机的窗户往外看，安妮塔告诉詹里：看到下面的河了吗？记得我们穿过河流的时候吗？记住那个。看下面，那就是妈妈在拘留中心的地方。那一刻，他们把这些抛在了身后。
Jeremy Raft with The Atlantic. He's making a documentary about this story. You can watch the trailer at theatlantic.com. Nadia Reiman is a producer for our show.
这是《大西洋月刊》的杰里米·拉夫。他正在为这个故事制作纪录片。你可以在theatlantic.com观看预告片。纳迪亚·雷曼是我们节目的制作人。
You may remember a few weeks ago, we did a story about another lawyer in Texas, Rochelle Garza, who's trying to get her client out of detention and reunite him with his 12-year-old daughter. Just the other day, we heard from them. She was finally able to get the dad out of custody, and he went out to pick up his daughter at the shelter she was at. They're together now and still in this country.
你可能记得几周前，我们做过关于德克萨斯州另一位律师罗谢尔·加尔萨（Rochelle Garza）的故事，她试图让她的当事人获释并与他12岁的女儿团聚。就在前几天，我们收到了他们的消息。她终于成功让那位父亲获释，并去收容所接回了他的女儿。他们现在团聚了，而且仍然留在这个国家。
Coming up, a whole part of ICE that does not want to be part of ICE, and what in the world do they do. That's in a minute on Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，一个不想成为ICE一部分的ICE部门，他们到底在做什么？稍后在芝加哥公共广播电台的节目中继续揭晓。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, ICE Capades We have two stories today about the agency, US immigration and Customs Enforcement. ICE is such a big agency and does so many things, prosecutes criminals, goes after terrorists, detains tens of thousands of immigrants. Sometimes, one part of the agency is actually at odds with the other parts. You see that in this next act of our program.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是“ICE闹剧”。今天我们有两个关于美国移民与海关执法局的故事。ICE是一个巨大的机构，做了很多事情：起诉罪犯、追捕恐怖分子、拘留成千上万的移民。有时，该机构的一个部分实际上与其他部分不和。你会在我们节目的下一部分看到这一点。
Act Two, The Iceman Cometh. Miki Meek has this story of two brothers who tried to turn the tables on somebody who was doing some pretty bad stuff to them. The way that ICE is involved will become clear as this unfolds. Here's Miki.
第二幕，冰人来了。米基·米克（Miki Meek）带来了两个试图反击某个一直在对他们做坏事的人的兄弟的故事。随着事情的发展，ICE是如何参与进来的将会变得清晰。这是米基的报道。
Back in 2012, Christina Corbaci had this meeting that was totally standard, something she'd done hundreds of times, that turned into something she'd never experienced. She's an immigration lawyer in Boston. Two brothers came in, Brigido and Walter, originally from Guatemala. They were living in the US without papers.
回到2012年，克里斯蒂娜·科巴奇（Christina Corbaci）参加了一个完全标准的会议，就像她参加过数百次的那样，但这变成了一次她从未经历过的体验。她是波士顿的一位移民律师。两兄弟走了进来，布里吉多（Brigido）和沃尔特（Walter），最初来自危地马拉。他们没有合法证件居住在美国。
I think they came in to talk about one of the brothers in particular, to find out what he and his wife, whether they had any options.
我想他们来是为了谈论其中一个兄弟的问题，想知道他和他的妻子是否有任何选择。
It didn't look good. He and his wife both had deportation orders. Christina told them.
情况不容乐观。他和他的妻子都有驱逐令。克里斯蒂娜告诉他们。
I doubt that there's any concrete real options for you to legalize your status right now. And then I remember them saying, OK, well, now that we've sort of gotten through this, we want to tell you why we're really here.
我怀疑你们目前是否有任何具体的合法化身份的选择。然后我记得他们说，好的，既然我们已经谈完这个了，我们要告诉您我们为什么真正来这里。
It was a test, and she passed. The brothers wanted to see if Christina would be honest about their chances. There's a whole world of people who prey on undocumented immigrants, tell them they can get them legal status when their cases are impossible. It's just a way to take their money. Because Christina passed the test, they spilled out the real reason why they were there. It was about an immigration official named Patria Zuniga. She worked for US citizenship and Immigration Services out of their Miami office. They met her through a friend, who said great things about Patria.
这是一个测试，而她通过了。两兄弟想看看克里斯蒂娜是否会对他们的机会坦诚相告。有一整群专门敲诈无证移民的人，告诉他们即使情况绝望也能帮他们获得合法身份。这只是为了骗钱。因为克里斯蒂娜通过了考验，他们吐露了来这里的真正原因。是关于一位名叫帕特里亚·祖尼加（Patria Zuniga）的移民官员。她在迈阿密办公室为美国公民及移民服务局（USCIS）工作。他们是通过一个朋友认识她的，那个朋友对帕特里亚评价很高。
Patria got her legal documents to travel out of the country in return. Patria was helping her whole family get green cards. So they called, and from that first conversation on the phone, Walter said she seemed super competent.
作为回报，帕特里亚帮她拿到了出国旅游的合法证件。帕特里亚还在帮她全家办理绿卡。所以他们打了电话，沃尔特说，从第一次通话开始，她看起来就非常精明。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
She was familiar with my immigration case. She mentioned the number of times that I had entered the US with a visa. She knew how many times my wife had applied for TPS.
她很熟悉我的移民案件。她提到了我持签证进入美国的次数。她知道我妻子申请TPS多少次了。
TPS stands for temporary protected status. It's a humanitarian program.
TPS代表“临时保护身份”。这是一个人道主义项目。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
And that gave me trust that she was going to help me.
这让我相信她会帮助我。
Patria told them their families were eligible for a particular category of green cards, and that she could help fast track their paperwork. But there'd be a cost, $7,000 for the children, and between $10,000 and $11,000 for each adult. The numbers didn't seem crazy to Brigido. They had lots of fines and violations to clear. But it'd be hard for them to pay all that money upfront. Brigido was a truck driver, and Walter worked construction and ran a small computer repair business. So Patria agreed to let them pay in installments. They used all their savings and started borrowing from family and friends.
帕特里亚告诉他们，他们的家庭有资格获得特定类别的绿卡，她可以帮他们加快办理手续。但这需要成本，孩子需要7000美元，每个成人则需要1万到1.1万美元。这对布里吉多来说数字并不疯狂。他们有很多罚款和违规记录要清理。但一次性支付所有这些钱对他们来说很困难。布里吉多是个卡车司机，沃尔特从事建筑工作并经营一家小型电脑维修公司。所以帕特里亚同意让他们分期付款。他们用光了所有积蓄，并开始向亲戚和朋友借钱。
And Patria actually drove out to pick up the payments in person. They liked her. She moved here from the Dominican Republic, and became a citizen herself. She came across as smart and confident, but also warm and down to earth, a real family person. She was in her late 40s, and sometimes she brought her two older daughters and grandkid. Patria told Brigido and Walter their green cards should be ready within three to six months, but then she said they hit some delays and extra fees. Patria would tell them, I'm going to need another $200 for mailing. Oh no, this fine came up on your file. That'll be another $1500.
帕特里亚甚至亲自开车来拿钱。他们喜欢她。她是从多米尼加共和国搬到这里的，并自己成为了公民。她给人的印象是聪明、自信，但也温暖、脚踏实地，是一个真正顾家的人。她四十多岁，有时还带着她的两个大女儿和孙子。帕特里亚告诉布里吉多和沃尔特，他们的绿卡应该在三到六个月内准备好，但后来她说遇到了一些延误和额外费用。帕特里亚会告诉他们：我还需要200美元邮寄费。噢，不，你的档案里出现了一笔罚款。那还需要1500美元。
They asked for receipts. She said she'd send them and never did. Then she started disappearing for weeks at a time before suddenly popping back up. Once, she told Walter that she'd had a heart attack.
他们要求收据。她说会寄给他们，却从未兑现。然后她开始消失几周，突然又冒出来。有一次，她告诉沃尔特她心脏病发作了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
But as soon as she got out of the hospital, she was going to Miami right away to get the papers.
但她一出院，就立刻去迈阿密拿文件。
They start to wonder if she's ever going to deliver, if they've been scammed. Months drag on. It was hard to talk about this with anyone. They felt ashamed for dragging their families into this. Walter had even referred one of his friends to Patria.
他们开始怀疑她是否会交出绿卡，怀疑自己是否被骗了。几个月过去了。和任何人谈论这件事都很困难。他们为把家人拖进这个深渊感到羞耻。沃尔特甚至介绍了一个朋友给帕特里亚。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I felt uncomfortable with myself, because I thought, how could I have fallen for this.
我对自己感到不舒服，因为我想，我怎么会落入这个圈套。
Patria's phone calls became more aggressive and threatening. She tells them, if they don't turn in all the money fast, she'll cancel their applications. She'll tell ICE agents where they live. Walter refuses to give her money. Brigido still holds out hope that she'll deliver. Going to the police didn't feel like an option, because they were undocumented. Here's Walter.
帕特里亚的电话变得越来越咄咄逼人和充满威胁。她告诉他们，如果他们不尽快交出所有钱，她就会取消他们的申请。她会告诉ICE探员他们住在哪里。沃尔特拒绝再给她钱。布里吉多仍然抱着她会交货的希望。去警察局感觉不是个选择，因为他们是无证件者。这是沃尔特。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
She says, look, If you report me, you're going to be sorry your entire life, because I have but to snap my fingers to deport you or to have you disappeared. I kept turning it over and over in my mind, and I said to myself, there's no way out. You failed.
她说，看，如果你举报我，你会后悔一辈子，因为我只需要动动手指就能驱逐你们，或者让你们消失。我一遍又一遍地在脑子里反刍，我对自己说，没有出路了。你失败了。
He and his wife both started to crack from stress. One day, driving on the highway, he blacked out, barely pulled over in time. All along, they were paying Patria in mostly cash. Walter said she told them straight out that the money was for bribes. She said she and her bosses in Miami had been helping people out like this for 15 years.
他和他的妻子都开始因压力而崩溃。有一天，在高速公路上开车时，他突然晕厥，勉强停在了路边。一直以来，他们大多是以现金支付给帕特里亚的。沃尔特说，她直接告诉他们这些钱是贿赂。她说她和她在迈阿密的老板这样帮人搞定身份已经15年了。
Walter says this would be totally normal back home in Guatemala, but his brother Brigido, he understood the payments differently. He thought these were real government fees, though after more than a year, he was fed up. He was out nearly $34,000. Walter was out $28,000. The two of them, they're very different personalities. Walter's talkative, wears his long hair in a ponytail. He used to teach at a university in Guatemala, and uses lots of big words when he speaks. Instead of saying, we had to clear our heads, he'll say we were oxygenating our minds.
沃尔特说这在危地马拉老家完全是正常的，但他的哥哥布里吉多对这些付款的理解不同。他认为这些是真正的政府规费，尽管一年多以后，他也受够了。他损失了近3.4万美元。沃尔特损失了2.8万美元。他们两人的性格截然不同。沃尔特健谈，留着长马尾辫。他过去在危地马拉的一所大学教书，说话时喜欢用大词。他不说“我们需要清醒一下头脑”，而是说“我们在给大脑补氧”。
Brigido's more reserved, quieter, but more of a leader. He's the older brother, and it's Brigido who decided to start an investigation. He found a guy named Rolando, who was sure Patria was about to deliver his papers. He just had to make one last payment.
布里吉多更内敛、安静，但更有领导力。他是哥哥，正是布里吉多决定开始调查。他找到了一个叫罗兰多（Rolando）的家伙，他坚信帕特里亚马上就要交出他的文件了。他只需要再交最后一笔钱。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
He still owed about $7,000 to Patria. And I asked him, would he be willing for us to try to come up with some evidence. And he said yes, and he asked me how to do this. So I said for him not to deliver cash, but money orders.
他还要给帕特里亚大约7000美元。我问他，是否愿意让我们试着搜集一些证据。他说愿意，并问我该怎么做。所以我建议他不要交现金，而是使用汇票。
He had Rolando go to the post office and purchase seven separate money orders, each for $1,000. He then sent them to Patria.
他让罗兰多去邮局买了七张独立的汇票，每张1000美元。然后他把它们寄给了帕特里亚。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
They should have been cashed by immigration, but instead, her daughters cashed them, and even she cashed in a money order. So that made it quite clear that this was a swindle.
它们本应由移民局兑现，但实际上是她的女儿们兑现的，甚至她自己也兑现了一张汇票。所以这很清楚地表明这是一场骗局。
Next, Brigido called a meeting in Worcester, where he lives. It's about an hour west of Boston, and has a big Central American community. He put out word through other undocumented immigrants in town that anyone who'd been in touch with Patria should meet him at a public park.
接下来，布里吉多在伍斯特召开了一次会议，他住在那里。伍斯特距离波士顿以西约一小时路程，有一个庞大的中美洲社区。他通过镇上的其他无证移民传话，任何与帕特里亚有联系的人都应该在公共公园见他。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
And there were about 40 people who showed up to this meeting in a park.
大约有40个人出现在公园的这次会议上。
This was the moment he realized her scam was much bigger than just him and his brother.
那一刻他意识到，她的骗局远不止针对他和他的弟弟。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I myself was surprised because I met people that I'd never seen before. Everyone was afraid. We were all afraid. And at that moment, I felt a lot of contempt for her, for what she had done.
我自己也很惊讶，因为我见到了以前从未见过的人。每个人都害怕。我们都很害怕。在那一刻，我为她所做的一切感到非常蔑视。
One woman said she lost $80,000. Other people had taken out high interest loans, second mortgages, or drained their kids' college funds to pay Patria. Lots of them met her the same way the brothers had, through one of their good friends in Worcester, a woman named Nubi Melendez, who was really close to Patria. People dropped off envelopes of cash for Patria at Nubi's house. Brigido purposely kept her in the dark about the meeting. He figured she was in on the scam.
一位妇女说她损失了8万美元。其他人则背负了高利贷、二抵房屋，或掏空了孩子的大学基金来支付给帕特里亚。许多人都是以同样的方式认识她的：通过他们在伍斯特的一位共同好友，一位名叫努比·梅伦德斯（Nubi Melendez）的妇女，她和帕特里亚关系非常好。人们把现金信封送到努比家里。布里吉多故意向她隐瞒了这次会议。他认为她是骗局的共犯。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I said we were all victims of Patria, that there was no doubt about it at that point, and that no one should hand over any more money, because it was a swindle. And I wanted to know who would be willing to pursue this to its final consequences. Everyone said they were.
我说我们都是帕特里亚的受害者，这一点毫无疑问，而且谁也不应该再交钱了，因为这是一场骗局。我想知道谁愿意追究到底。每个人都说愿意。
When you say final consequences, what did that mean?
当你说“追究到底”时，那意味着什么？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
That she might carry out her threats to report us to immigration and have us deported.
那就是她可能会落实她的威胁，向移民局举报我们并将我们驱逐出境。
Sure, it was dangerous to go after a corrupt immigration official. But by that point, the feeling was, so what. Patria had all their information. She was probably going to get them deported anyway. Again, here's Walter.
当然，去对抗一名腐败的移民官员是很危险的。但到了那个地步，感觉是：那又怎样。帕特里亚掌握了他们所有的信息。她可能无论如何都会把他们举报给驱逐出境。再一次，这是沃尔特。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I was not going to stay silent. I was going to find a way for that woman to pay for what she had done, because what was the worst that could happen. We'd be deported to Guatemala. Well, we came to a point where we said, it doesn't matter.
我不会保持沉默。我会找到一种方法让那个女人为她所做的一切付出代价，因为最坏的结果能是什么呢？我们被驱逐回危地马拉。好吧，我们已经到了那个地步，说：没关系。
And so this is how days later, Brigido and Walter landed in Christina Corbachi's office. At that meeting at the park, everyone decided Brigido should find a lawyer to talk to. People started calling him Don Brigido as a sign of their respect. So he and Walter went online to research law firms. They chose Christina's because they saw that her boss was a retired immigration judge, they trusted that someone like him would know how to report Patria. His name is William Joyce, and he did have a thought for Christina.
于是几天后，布里吉多和沃尔特来到了克里斯蒂娜·科巴奇的办公室。在公园的那次会议上，每个人都决定布里吉多应该找个律师谈谈。人们开始叫他“布里吉多先生”（Don Brigido）以示尊重。所以他和沃尔特上网研究律师事务所。他们选择了克里斯蒂娜的事务所，因为他们看到她的老板是一位退休的移民法官，他们信任像他这样的人会知道如何举报帕特里亚。他的名字叫威廉·乔伊斯（William Joyce），他确实有一个主意给克里斯蒂娜。
He was like, hmm, why don't we call ICE.
他说：嗯，我们为什么不打给ICE呢。
ICE is in a federal building right across the street from the firm in downtown Boston.
ICE就在波士顿市中心那家律所的正对面，在一栋联邦大楼里。
And that was like the last thing I would have thought of, because to me, that was like, oh, yeah, let's, you know, call ICE on these people who are undocumented.
那是我最想不到的事情，因为对我来说，就像是，噢，天哪，让我们打给ICE去举报这些无证件者吧。
Who just showed up because they trusted you. I mean, when he said that, what was going through your head, when he said that?
这些无证件者仅仅因为信任你才出现。当他说那句话时，你脑子里在想什么？
Like, oh, I don't know about that. I guess my first thought was, like, well, what about the police, right, local police.
我不知道。我猜我第一个想法是，好吧，那警察呢，对吧，当地警察。
It just didn't seem that there was any possible way that going directly to ICE, the agency best known for arresting, detaining, and deporting undocumented immigrants, would end well for Brigido and Walter. Even if they got Patria fired and all their money back, wouldn't ICE have to deport them? But then Christina's boss told her about a separate division within ICE that most people have never heard of, Homeland Security investigations, or HSI. ICE has two big branches. There's the side that does deportations, and then there's this other branch, HSI, which does other kinds of criminal investigations broadly having to do with national security.
直接去找ICE——那个以逮捕、拘留和驱逐无证移民而闻名的机构——似乎没有任何好结果的可能。即使他们让帕特里亚被解雇并拿回所有的钱，ICE难道不还是会驱逐他们吗？但后来克里斯蒂娜的老板告诉她，ICE内部有一个大多数人从未听说过的独立部门：国土安全调查处（HSI）。ICE有两个大分支。一个是负责驱逐的一面，然后是这个分支，HSI，它负责其他各类广泛与国家安全有关的刑事调查。
They go after human trafficking, money laundering, MS-13, child pornography, and anyone messing with the immigration system. Last year, they were in the news for helping capture the drug lord, El Chapo. HSI is actually the second largest investigative agency after the FBI, with more than 6,000 special agents. Anyway, Christina's boss knew some people at HSI and told her, we don't need to give them any personal details now. Let me just reach out. And HSI, they got back to them, said sure, we'll send an agent over. Remember, they're right across the street.
他们打击人口贩运、洗钱、MS-13帮派、儿童色情，以及任何干扰移民系统的人。去年，他们因协助抓捕毒枭“矮子”古兹曼（El Chapo）而登上新闻。HSI实际上是继FBI之后的第二大调查机构，拥有超过6000名特别探员。总之，克里斯蒂娜的老板认识HSI里的一些人，告诉她：我们现在不需要给他们任何个人信息。让我先联系一下。HSI回复了他们，说没问题，我们会派一名探员过去。记住，他们就在街对面。
I didn't know whether I could trust them. I mean, logically it seemed like we should be able to. But it's almost like we were delivering them into their hands.
我不知道我能不能相信他们。我的意思是，逻辑上似乎我们应该可以。但简直就像我们正把他们送进他们手里一样。
And then, are you guys, is there any formal assurances you're getting from ICE? Does anything get signed?
那你们有得到ICE的任何正式保证吗？有签署什么东西吗？
It was all verbal.
全是口头的。
That's so nerve wracking.
那太让人神经紧张了。
Yeah.
是啊。
The agency promised that they didn't care about anyone's immigration status. They just wanted to get more information about Patria's crime. Still, the very idea of meeting with ICE scared off most people from the park. Out of that group of 40, only five or six other people said they'd show up with Walter and Brigido. The brothers were terrified too. Walter had overstayed his visa, and Brigido had a deportation order. Their wives decide to skip it. So Brigido, Walter and the others showed up early for the meeting.
该机构承诺他们不关心任何人的移民身份。他们只是想获得更多关于帕特里亚犯罪的信息。尽管如此，直接去见ICE的想法还是吓跑了公园里的大多数人。在那40人中，只有五六个人说愿意和沃尔特与布里吉多一起去。两兄弟也非常恐惧。沃尔特逾期居留，布里吉多有驱逐令。他们的妻子决定不去。所以布里吉多、沃尔特和其余几个人提早赶到了会议现场。
They sat waiting around a giant conference room table, swiveling nervously in leather chairs on wheels. And then an agent from HSI walked in and introduced himself, a scruffy guy in t-shirt and jeans.
他们坐在巨大的会议桌旁，紧张地在有轮子的真皮椅子上转来转去。然后一位来自HSI的探员走进来介绍了自己，一个穿着T恤牛仔裤的邋遢家伙。
Special Agent Robert Rice. I'm an agent with the document and benefit fraud task force.
特别探员罗伯特·赖斯（Robert Rice）。我是证件和福利欺诈特遣队的探员。
Agent Rice told me he agreed to the meeting with the lowest possible expectations. Normally, he did a lot of financial crimes and identity fraud, complex schemes where people were forging documents and lying to the government. He had never done a case like this, and when he strolled in, he didn't actually expect to find people there.
赖斯探员告诉我，他以最低的期望值答应了这次会议。通常他处理很多金融犯罪和身份欺诈，那些复杂的骗局，有人伪造文件和向政府撒谎。他从未处理过这样的案子，当他晃晃悠悠走进来时，他其实没指望能找到人。
I've never seen anything like it. These were for the most part, undocumented aliens. They don't come running to law enforcement, especially Homeland Security investigations. So this was completely-- and I've been doing this for 21 years now, so I was just so curious, wanting to see who were these people, and what did they have to say.
我从来没见过这种场面。他们绝大多数是无证外籍人士。他们不会主动跑来找执法部门，尤其是国土安全调查处。所以这完全是——我已经干了21年了，所以我非常好奇，想看看这些人到底是谁，他们想说什么。
What are you doing to put people at ease?
你做了什么让人们放松警惕？
I began my career as a border patrol agent in Douglas, Arizona. So I think I know what was going through their heads. I thought they were afraid of me. Now, I wanted to, right off the bat I wanted to end that.
我的职业生涯是从亚利桑那州道格拉斯的边境巡逻探员开始的。所以我想我知道他们心里在想什么。我以为他们怕我。现在，我想从一开始就结束这种恐惧。
So in some pretty bad Spanish, he attempted to make a joke about ICE, although he couldn't remember the Spanish for me.
所以他用非常蹩脚的西班牙语试图讲一个关于ICE的笑话，尽管他不记得“我”的西班牙语怎么说。
I was like, you know, we're not coming here, we're not parking the vans out front. We're not going to stand there with nets trying to jump you and drag you out of the country. And everyone laughed at that.
我说，你知道，我们没来这里，我们没把面包车停在前门。我们不会站在那儿拿着网试图抓住你们，把你们拖出这个国家。大家都被逗笑了。
Again, here is Brigido.
再一次，这是布里吉多。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
We all laughed.
我们都笑了。
It's such a weird scene.
这是一个如此怪异的场景。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Well, it was a surprise, but at the same time, it broke the ice.
好吧，这很意外，但同时，它打破了僵局（ice）。
The agent from ICE broke the ice.
这位来自ICE的探员打破了僵局。
Yeah.
是啊。
Agent Rice's job is to enforce the laws on the books. A crime is a crime, no matter the legal status of the victims. He told them--
赖斯探员的工作是执行现有法律。犯罪就是犯罪，无论受害者的法律身份如何。他告诉他们——
I don't care what your status is, I'm here to help you. I want to know, just tell me what happened to you, what are the allegations you're making. And that's how we proceeded.
我不在乎你们的身份，我是来帮你们的。我想知道，只要告诉我你们身上发生了什么，你们提出的指控是什么。我们就是这样进行的。
What kind of assurances can you give and can you not give to a group of people like this?
你可以对这样一群人给出什么样的保证，又不能给出什么样的保证？
We never promise anything, but none of these people had criminal records, and so I had prosecutorial discretion to not enforce immigration laws.
我们从不承诺任何事，但这些人都没有犯罪记录，所以我拥有检控裁量权，不去执行移民法。
He says he still has this discretion today, even though so much has changed in the agency under President Trump and so many more people are being deported. That first meeting at the law firm was short, less than an hour, and Rice says he purposely kept it informal. He didn't even write down names, in case it spooked anyone. But he did want Brigido, Walter and the others to know they could trust him. So he took out his HSI badge and passed it around the table. Walter remembers holding it and and Rice telling them--
他说即使在特朗普总统治下该机构发生了如此多的变化，甚至有更多人被驱逐，他今天仍然拥有这种裁量权。在律师事务所的第一次会议很短，不到一小时，赖斯说他故意保持非正式。他甚至没记名字，以免吓到任何人。但他确实希望布里吉多、沃尔特和其他人知道他们可以信任他。所以他拿出他的HSI徽章，在桌上转了一圈。沃尔特记得拿着它，赖斯告诉他们——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Take it. Feel it. Examine it. This is legal. Did she show you something like that? And I said no.
拿住它。摸摸它。检查它。这是合法的。她给你们看过这种东西吗？我说没有。
Brigido and Rolando showed Rice the money order receipts. Rice was impressed, but it wasn't enough for a federal case. He needed way more evidence. And he needed to understand the extent of the crime. Fairly quickly, he was able to verify that Patria did not work for US Citizenship and Immigration Services, in Miami or anywhere else. She was an imposter. All that paperwork she was supposed to be filing for them, none of it existed in the system. Walter and Brigido were outraged and embarrassed that they'd been tricked so badly.
布里吉多和罗兰多给赖斯看了汇票收据。赖斯印象深刻，但这对联邦案件来说还不够。他需要更多证据。他需要了解犯罪的程度。很快，他确认了帕特里亚并未在迈阿密或其他任何地方为美国公民及移民服务局工作。她是一个骗子。她本应帮他们提交的所有文书工作，在系统中根本不存在。沃尔特和布里吉多对自己被骗得如此惨感到愤怒和尴尬。
Agent Rice visited Patria, who denied knowing any of the victims, said she didn't know what they were talking about. Next, Rice needed to track down as many victims as he could. The fact that most people paid in cash was a huge hurdle for the case. He hoped he'd find someone who saved some kind of corroborating documentation, contracts, receipts, bank deposit slips, tax, e-mails, audio recordings, and that they'd talk to him.
赖斯探员拜访了帕特里亚，她否认认识任何受害者，说不知道他们在说什么。接下来，赖斯需要尽可能多地追踪受害者。绝大多数人以现金支付是一个巨大的障碍。他希望能找到保存了某种协同证明文件的人，合同、收据、银行存款单、税单、电子邮件、录音，并且他们愿意跟他说话。
So there was no record trail, and that was the scariest part. It's just, a lot of it we couldn't prove. And I was literally chasing people all over the place. They wouldn't answer my phone calls, wouldn't answer the door. Wanted nothing to do with me. You feel the tension, and that was constant. That was tough.
所以没有记录追踪，那是最可怕的部分。很多东西我们无法证明。我简直是在到处追着人跑。他们不接电话，不开门。不想和我扯上关系。你能感觉到那种紧张，那是持续的。那是艰难的。
They look at you as being like, you are too big of a threat for me to get into this.
他们把你视为——你是一个太大的威胁，我不去触碰。
They're still afraid of me as an immigration officer. The fear of being deported and being separated from their family outweighed any benefit that they thought they could've received.
他们仍然把我视为移民官员而感到害怕。被驱逐和与家人分离的恐惧超过了他们认为可能获得的任何利益。
This is why it's so hard to crack down on scammers who victimize undocumented immigrants. They're the perfect victims, desperate for help and not likely to go to law enforcement, much less stick around for years to testify at a trial. So these scams are pervasive. Rice held two more meetings at the law office, and more people from the park showed up. And Rice asked Brigido and Walter to reach out to the other people they knew, and call them right before he did.
这就是为什么打击那些掠夺无证移民的骗子如此困难的原因。他们是完美的受害者，急于寻求帮助，却不太可能去求助执法部门，更不用说坚持多年在审判中作证了。所以这些骗局很普遍。赖斯在律所开了两次会议，更多来自公园的人出现了。赖斯要求布里吉多和沃尔特联系他们认识的其他人，并在他联系之前给他们打电话。
And they would say like, no, he's helping us, he's not arresting anybody. So they really helped me. They really opened the door for me, and this whole subculture of Worcester, of this Central American community. I depended on them, just little things that couldn't have been accomplished by myself.
他们会说，不，他在帮我们，他没在抓人。所以他们真的帮了我。他们真的为我打开了大门，进入了伍斯特这个中美洲社区的整个亚文化。我依赖他们，一些靠我自己根本无法完成的小事。
This was the beginning of an unlikely partnership, a partnership that was improbable then and even more improbable now. ICE, the agency that in the last months has been part of the zero tolerance policy, the agency that immigration activists are now calling to be abolished completely, they were going to team up with a group of undocumented immigrants. Brigido told me there were lots of people who didn't want an ICE agent to stop by their house and sit in their living room, who didn't want to set foot in ICE's office in Boston. So Brigido organized a workaround. It was a hair salon in Worcester. The owner was also a victim, and said sure. You can use my place. Rice met with people there.
这是一个不太可能的伙伴关系的开始，一个当时不可能、现在更不可能的伙伴关系。ICE，那个在过去几个月中一直参与“零容忍”政策的机构，那个移民活动人士现在呼吁彻底废除的机构，竟然要与一群无证移民合作。布里吉多告诉我，有很多人不希望ICE探员去他们家、坐在客厅里，不希望踏入位于波士顿的ICE办公室。所以布里吉多组织了一个折中方案。那是一家位于伍斯特的美发沙龙。店主也是受害者，说没问题。你可以用我的地方。赖斯在那里和人们见面。
Initially, she would close it up, and we would all meet in the back. And then later on, I mean, next thing, I became close to-- everyone knew me. The whole street knew who I was. And they'd still be cutting hair or doing dyes, or doing nails, and I'd be meeting people in the back. I'm making it convenient for them. I mean, this is my job. I have all day. I had all day, almost like 900 days in a row, I was driving back and forth to Worcester and wherever.
起初，她会关门，我们都在后面开会。后来，我的意思是，接下来，我变得和大家很熟——整条街都知道我是谁。他们还在剪发、染发或做指甲，而我就在后面见受害者。我让这对他们很方便。我的意思是，这是我的工作。我有的是时间。我有的是时间，几乎像连续900天一样，我都在往返于伍斯特和各地。
For 2 and 1/2 years, he met people at construction sites and fast food joints when they were on breaks from their jobs, other times in random parking lots. Walter and Brigido didn't know lots of the victims, so Rice had to cold call them.
在两年半的时间里，他在工地和快餐店里见他们，当他们从工作中休息时，其他时候则在随机的停车场。沃尔特和布里吉多不认识很多受害者，所以赖斯必须去进行陌生拜访。
Knock on the door, hi, how you doing, with a badge. And it's instant. You only have a short window to--
敲门，嗨，你好吗，带着徽章。这是即时的。你只有很短的窗口期去——
How short?
多短？
Well, you're talking minutes, I mean, to be, don't worry, you know, I'm not here-- You know, when you're doing this to somebody, and they're undocumented, and I was like, I explained to them, I'm not here for your immigration status. I want to talk to you about, were you a victim of this person, did you give this person money. When you said Patria's Zuniga to these people, that was for a second at least, I mean, you could see it in their eyes, and they knew where I was going. It seems, kind of more often than not, really, they're willing to talk. They wanted to talk.
嗯，说话只有几分钟，我的意思是，要让他们别担心，你知道，我不是来——你知道，当你对某人做这个，而他们是无证件者时，我向他们解释，我不是为了你们的移民身份。我想和你谈谈，你是否是这个人的受害者，你是否给了这个人钱。当你对这些人说“帕特里亚·祖尼加”时，至少有一秒钟，我的意思是，你能从他们的眼中看到，他们知道我要干什么。似乎，更多时候，真的，他们愿意交谈。他们想谈。
And you know, the first thing that struck me was, they're all over the place. They're in Worcester, they're in Lynn, they're in parts of Boston, they're in Framingham. We're talking hundreds of square miles where they were located, and the stories never changed. If one person said, I met them on this occasion, and this is how much money. I mean, the money amount never changed. The dates never changed. Everything was consistent. And that goes towards trustworthiness as far as I'm concerned.
你知道，第一件让我震惊的事情是，他们到处都是。他们在伍斯特，在林恩，在波士顿的部分地区，在弗雷明汉。我们谈论的是几百平方英里的范围，他们的故事从未改变。如果一个人说，我在这个场合见到他们，给了多少钱。我的意思是，金额从未改变。日期从未改变。一切都是一致的。就我而言，这代表了可信度。
Still, he wasn't getting much hard documentary evidence. If Patria had filed fraudulent green card applications with the government, they could charge her with immigration fraud, but her scheme never went that far. So he had to look for a financial crime. But this was tough, because Patria had no bank account. Her two daughters did, and Rice did see a lot of cash deposits, but he couldn't trace them back to specific payments that immigrants made to Patria.
尽管如此，他还是没有获得多少过硬的纪录证据。如果帕特里亚向政府提交了虚假的绿卡申请，他们可以以移民欺诈罪起诉她，但她的骗局从未走到那一步。所以他必须寻找金融犯罪。但这很难，因为帕特里亚没有银行账户。她的两个女儿有，赖斯确实看到了大量的现金存款，但他无法将其追踪到移民支付给帕特里亚的具体款项。
I spent so much time tracking people down, and they dug through their records and their memories, and at the end of the day, they weren't good witnesses because they had nothing but, they were just telling me that, you know, they gave money to her.
我花了太多时间追踪人们，他们翻阅记录和记忆，但最终，他们不是好的证人，因为他们除了告诉我给了她钱之外什么都没有。
They had nothing, they didn't have a receipt for you. They didn't have any documentation.
他们没有收据。他们没有任何文件。
No documentation.
没有文件。
There was one person in particular Rice wanted to get to, the woman who people saw as Patria's co-conspirator, Nubi Melendez. Her house was like a base for Patria in Worcester. Patria met with people there. She told people to leave their money with Nubi when she couldn't come to town. When it came time to confront Nubi, Agent Rice went to her house and sat in the driveway and waited.
有一个人赖斯特别想找到，那个被大家视为帕特里亚同谋的女人，努比·梅伦德斯。她的房子就像帕特里亚在伍斯特的基地。帕特里亚在那里会见人们。当她不能去镇上时，她告诉人们把钱留在努比那里。当需要面对努比时，赖斯探员去了她家，坐在车道上等着。
She was just coming back. She just picked up her daughter from school and she was walking home. And then all of the sudden, there's HSI agents in your driveway. And I was like, I'd like to ask some questions about Patria Zuniga.
她正好刚回来。她刚从学校接了女儿，正在步行回家。突然，HSI探员出现在你的车道上。我说，我想问一些关于帕特里亚·祖尼加的问题。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
This is Nubi.
这是努比。
And they said, are you Nubi Melendez. My heart jumped out of me, practically.
他们说，你是努比·梅伦德斯吗？我的心几乎都要跳出来了。
Who did you think he was?
你以为他是谁？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I don't know. His appearance had lots of tattoos.
我不知道。他的外表有很多纹身。
I'm not the tall white guy with a flat top wearing the suit, and you can see I'm unshaven.
我不是那个穿着西装、留着平头的白人高个子，你可以看到我没刮胡子。
You got a goatee.
你有山羊胡。
I have tattoos. My government car's a Saturn. Basically, a soccer mom car. I want to look like just the guy on the street.
我有纹身。我的政府用车是一辆土星。基本上是一辆足球妈妈车。我只想看起来像个街头的路人。
I got to admit, I was amused when Nubi told me that his guy on the street strategy backfired with her at first.
我得承认，当努比告诉我他的“街头路人”策略起初在她那里适得其反时，我感到很有趣。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
To me, he looked like a bad guy, a bad dude, but he's everything but that. Little by little, he started gaining our trust.
对我来说，他看起来像个坏人，一个坏家伙，但他除了那样什么都是。一点一点地，他开始赢得我们的信任。
Turns out, Nubi was not Patria's partner in crime. She, like all the others, was being ripped off.
事实证明，努比并不是帕特里亚犯罪的同伙。她和所有其他人一样，都被骗了。
I mean, at the end of the day, she was a victim probably more so than anybody else. Because not only did she lose all of her money, she lost all of her friends.
我的意思是，说到底，她比任何人都更像是一个受害者。因为她不仅损失了所有的钱，还失去了所有的朋友。
Patria had used Nubi as a launch pad to get to all her family and friends in Worcester. They had met through a coworker at McDonald's, and they got really close, or Nubi thought so, anyway. Patria came to her family parties, called all the time just to check in, and visited Nubi in the hospital when she was sick. Nubi had even started thinking about making her the godmother of her son, which is why she felt comfortable introducing her to so many people in Worcester. And the reason Nubi was collecting envelopes of cash for Patria, she told Rice it was because Patria had asked her to. Said, if you do me this favor, I'll give your family a good discount on her fees.
帕特里亚利用努比作为跳板，接触到了她在伍斯特所有的家人和朋友。她们是通过麦当劳的同事认识的，关系非常好，或者努比是这么认为的。帕特里亚参加她的家庭聚会，经常打电话只是为了问候，在努比生病时去医院探望她。努比甚至开始考虑让她做儿子的教母，这就是为什么她感到安心，把她介绍给伍斯特这么多人。努比收集现金信封的原因，她告诉赖斯是因为帕特里亚让她这么做的。说：如果你帮我这个忙，我就给你家很好的折扣。
So Nubi did it. But like the others, Nubi's family never got the green cards from Patria they were promised. One time, they seemed really close. Patria told her, the one for your little sister Alba is ready. Just come up to the immigration office in Boston and pick it up. Nubi and the whole family got dressed up, drove up to the office and waited outside like Patria had instructed them. Someone was supposed to come get them. Here's Nubi's little sister Alba. She was in high school at the time.
所以努比照办了。但像其他人一样，努比一家从未收到帕特里亚承诺的绿卡。有一次，似乎真的很近了。帕特里亚告诉她：你小妹妹阿尔芭（Alba）的那张已经准备好了。去波士顿的移民局拿一下就行。努比和全家精心打扮，开车去了办公室，像帕特里亚指示的那样等在外面。有人应该出来接他们。这是努比的小妹妹阿尔芭。她当时还在读高中。
We were there from the afternoon until I remember it being dark, and I'm like, we're still waiting here. I just kept, call her, call her, what's going on. But she don't answer.
我们从下午一直待到我记得天都黑了，我就想，我们还在等吗？我一直催，打给她，打给她，发生了什么。但她没接。
So she never showed up that day.
所以她那天从没出现。
No, she never showed up.
不，她从没出现。
Patria did this to other people too. One guy actually flew all the way out to the immigration office in Chicago, and the same thing. No one showed up. As always, Patria had an excuse. But Alba, the teenager, was done. Obama had just signed the executive order that created DACA, and because Alba had been brought into the country when she was just a kid, she was eligible. Patria told her not to apply.
帕特里亚也对别人这样做。有一个人甚至一直飞到芝加哥的移民局，结果一样。没有人出来。一如既往，帕特里亚有借口。但少年阿尔芭受够了。奥巴马刚刚签署了创建DACA的行政命令，因为阿尔芭在还是个孩子时就被带入了这个国家，她有资格。帕特里亚告诉她不要申请。
She told me, if you go for that, that I could possibly be deported because I'm already filing paperwork that's already ending, and me starting another paperwork could cause a problem. So I'm like, I'm not changing my mind. I'm filing for it, and I don't care. Alba did get DACA status, and right away, her family saw a big difference from the way things had been going with Patria. There were regular updates from the US government, official documents arriving in the mail, things they never got from Patria.
她告诉我，如果你去申请那个，我可能会被驱逐，因为我已经在办理的文书工作即将结束，如果开始另一项文书工作可能会造成问题。所以我像是说，我没改变主意。我要申请，我不在乎。阿尔芭确实获得了DACA身份，而且立刻，她家发现与帕特里亚那时的情况有很大不同。美国政府定期更新，正式文件送达邮件，这些在帕特里亚那里从未得到过。
So when Agent Rice showed up at their house, Alba and Nubi were more than willing to help.
所以当赖斯探员出现在他们家时，阿尔芭和努比非常乐意帮忙。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I knew that I had to say what had happened even if it had been bad. I had to say how it had happened.
我知道即使结果很糟，我也必须说出发生了什么。我必须说出它是怎么发生的。
She says the guilt was intense. People were shunning her in town, and calling her all the time to yell at her. She switched to English here.
她说那种负罪感非常强烈。人们在镇上避开她，并一直打电话给她大吼大叫。她在这里切换到了英语。
Everything he needed, I had to find it.
他需要的一切，我都必须找到。
Nubi became a central witness, and she gave Rice some important leads. One time when Rice was at her house, Nubi's phone rang, and it was Patria. Rice had a recording device with him, and so they taped the call. Brigido also started taping calls and giving them to Rice. In this call, Patria is pushing Brigido's wife for more money. Patria talks to her, though, like she's her friend, just trying to help her out.
努比成为了一名关键证人，并给赖斯提供了一些重要线索。有一次赖斯在她家时，努比的电话响了，是帕特里亚。赖斯随身带着录音设备，所以他们录下了通话。布里吉多也开始录音并交给赖斯。在那通电话里，帕特里亚正逼着布里吉多的妻子交更多的钱。帕特里亚和她说话时，听起来就像她的朋友，只是想帮她一把。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
She's saying, I know how much this means to you, and it would hurt me to see you throw it all away now after you've come so far.
她说，我知道这对你意味着什么，在你走了这么远之后，看到你把它全部抛弃，我会很伤心的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Patria insinuates that Nubi is the one taking everyone's payments for herself. She says in a confidential tone, I don't trust Nubi.
帕特里亚暗示努比是那个为自己收取每个人款项的人。她以一种私密的口吻说，我不信任努比。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Nubi, Brigido and Walter all said one of the scariest parts of the investigation was having to keep up a front so long with Patria. They were told not to confirm her suspicions that she was the target of a federal investigation, not while Agent Rice was still gathering evidence. And so when Patria harassed them and threatened them, they had to just play along, telling her, we just need a little more time to get the money. No, we're not helping law enforcement. To finally indict Patria, Rice and government prosecutors needed to present their evidence to multiple grand juries.
努比、布里吉多和沃尔特都说，调查中最可怕的部分之一就是必须在帕特里亚面前演戏太久。他们被告知不要确认她对自己是联邦调查目标的怀疑，至少在赖斯探员还在搜集证据时不能。所以当帕特里亚骚扰和威胁他们时，他们不得不顺从，告诉她：我们只是需要多一点时间筹钱。不，我们没在帮执法部门。为了最终起诉帕特里亚，赖斯和政府检察官需要向多个大陪审团提交证据。
He delivered subpoenas to Brigido, Nubi, and Walter, who was in the middle of working a job at a construction site when he pulled up. They all knew this was coming. Rice reminded them, this wasn't a suggestion. This was a court order. This was real. Rice said some of the government attorneys he was working with at the time thought this might be the moment when their case would fall apart.
他向布里吉多、努比和沃尔特送达了传票，沃尔特当时正在建筑工地工作。他们都知道这一天会来。赖斯提醒他们，这不是建议。这是法院命令。这是真的。赖斯说，和他一起工作的政府律师当时以为这可能是他们的案件崩溃的时刻。
The first prosecutor, she did not believe they were going to show up. She thought they were all going to disappear. Undocumented aliens do not have a long track record of showing up for grand jury, and that was always, always, that was constant. Are they going to disappear? Can we maintain this relationship? Can I maintain this relationship?
第一位检察官，她不相信他们会出席。她认为他们都会消失。无证外籍人士没有在大陪审团出庭的长期记录，那总是、总是——那是持续不断的。“他们会消失吗？我们能维持这种关系吗？我能维持这种关系吗？”
Brigido had to trust him too. When he got the subpoena, he had a talk with his wife and kids about what might happen.
布里吉多也必须信任他。当他收到传票时，他和妻子及孩子谈了可能发生的情况。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Well, as a joke, I said that if I didn't come back, we'd see each other over there.
嗯，作为玩笑，我说如果我没回来，我们会在那边相见。
Over there meeting in Guatemala.
在那边，在危地马拉相见。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
But in a more serious way, the sentiment was that everything might suddenly flip, and we'd all be arrested.
但在更严肃的层面上，那种情绪是：一切可能突然翻盘，我们会被全部逮捕。
It's hard to overstate how weird this whole thing was for them. They trusted Agent Rice. They knew he'd wait outside the courthouse and walk them in. But Brigido told me they still had this fear that Patria might actually have some connections in immigration. Maybe it was a trap.
很难夸大这一切对他们来说有多么怪异。他们信任赖斯探员。他们知道他会在法院外等他们，带他们进去。但布里吉多告诉我，他们仍然有一种恐惧，帕特里亚可能在移民局确实有一些关系。也许是个陷阱。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
On the other hand, there was courage, because that woman, when we recalled everything she had stolen from us, we felt renewed courage to push ahead so that she would pay the consequences.
另一方面，有勇气，因为那个女人，当我们回想起她从我们这里偷走的一切，我们感到一种重燃的勇气，向前推进，让她付出代价。
They went into the grand jury room by themselves, and they sat there by themselves. They did it. I can't say enough. I was proud of them.
他们独自走进大陪审团房间，独自坐在那里。他们做到了。我说不出太多。我为他们感到骄傲。
The grand jury voted yes for federal prosecutors to move forward with investigating fraud charges against Patria Zuniga. And Rice had other breakthroughs. He subpoenaed a ton of financial records, and found the names of new victims, people who paid through Western Union or bank deposits rather than cash like so many others, and who actually saved their receipts. Rice finally had what he needed to make a proper paper trail.
大陪审团投票同意联邦检察官推进对帕特里亚·祖尼加的欺诈指控调查。赖斯还有其他突破。他传唤了海量的财务记录，发现了新受害者的名字，那些通过西联汇款或银行存款而不是现金支付的人，他们确实保存了收据。赖斯终于有了制作正规文件追踪所需的一切。
All of the he said, she said, became, good god, look at the amounts of money. That's when, you know, the light bulb, the proverbial light bulb went off, and I was like wow, this is real.
所有那些“他说的”、“她说的”，变成了“天哪，看看这些钱的金额”。那时，你知道，灯泡，那句谚语中的灯泡亮了，我像是说：哇，这是真的。
The total amount Patria stole was startling, more than $700,000. And that was just from the victims who were willing to come forward. Even more surprising is where the money went. Patria, it turns out, was a huge gambler. There were records of her losing over $175,000 on slot machines at a Rhode Island casino. The rest of it was spent by her daughters on vacations, cell phone bills, Dunkin' Donuts. Nobody was getting their money back. In fact, lots of them are still paying off bank loans and relatives they'd borrowed from.
帕特里亚偷窃的总金额惊人：超过70万美元。而且这还只是那些愿意站出来的受害者的钱。更令人惊讶的是钱的去向。原来，帕特里亚是个超级赌徒。有记录显示她在罗德岛一家赌场的角子机上输掉了超过17.5万美元。剩下的钱被她的女儿们挥霍在度假、手机账单、甜甜圈店上。没有人能拿回他们的钱。事实上，许多人仍在偿还银行贷款和他们借钱的亲戚。
Agent Rice and his team went in for the arrest. Rice says if she was surprised, she didn't show it.
赖斯探员和他的团队进行了逮捕。赖斯说，如果她感到惊讶，她没表现出来。
You know, I went over and knocked on the door, and the door opens, and Patria's standing there, and she looks at me and she goes, hello, Rice. [LAUGHS] Just like that.
你知道，我过去敲门，门开了，帕特里亚站在那里，她看着我，她说：你好，赖斯。[笑] 就这样。
She pled guilty to eight counts of federal wire fraud. That's eventually what they got her on. Her daughters were arrested too. Probably the most moving day of this whole story came on June 28, 2016, the day that Patria Zuniga was finally sentenced, about four years after Brigido and the others met up in the park and decided to take her down. It happened in the federal courthouse in Worcester, the epicenter for the whole thing.
她承认了八项联邦电信欺诈罪。最终他们是以这个罪名抓到她的。她的女儿们也被捕了。整个故事中最动人的一天可能是2016年6月28日，那是帕特里亚·祖尼加最终被宣判的日子，距离布里吉多和其他人在公园聚会决定拉她下马大约四年。这发生在伍斯特的联邦法院，那是整个事件的中心。
The assistant US attorney who prosecuted the case, Jordi de Llano, encouraged them to come to the sentencing. If they wanted, they could stand up in court and read a statement to the judge, explaining how much Patria had harmed them. The judge is allowed to take that into consideration when deciding the sentence.
起诉此案的联邦助理检察官约尔迪·德·利亚诺（Jordi de Llano）鼓励他们参加判决。如果愿意，他们可以站在法庭上向法官宣读声明，解释帕特里亚对他们造成了多大的伤害。法官在决定刑期时可以参考这一点。
Around 8:00 in the morning, I started getting calls from downstairs saying there are a lot of people here that don't speak English. And I went downstairs and I was taken aback. I was floored with how many people showed up. It was the victims, their family members. They brought children. They brought babies.
早上8点左右，我开始接到楼下打来的电话说，有很多不会说英语的人在这里。我下楼后大吃一惊。出席的人数之多让我感到震撼。是受害者、他们的家属。他们带了孩子。他们带了婴儿。
In total, 57 people, almost all undocumented or with temporary status, agreed to have their names listed as victims for the government. I wasn't allowed to record in the courthouse, but I was there for this, and the scene was powerful. Families streamed in dressed up in pressed white shirts, slacks and skirts, carrying with them statements that they'd prepared in advance. Teenagers came to speak on behalf of their parents in English.
总共有57个人，几乎全是无证件者或持临时身份者，同意将他们的名字作为政府受害者名单列出。我不被允许在法庭内录音，但我亲历了这一切，场面非常震撼。家属们穿着整洁的白衬衫、长裤和裙子蜂拥而入，随身带着他们预先准备好的陈述。青少年们用英语代表他们的父母发言。
They came to support each other as well as to share their stories. That was a packed house. It was standing room only, I think, in that courtroom, and it went on for about eight hours. It was moving in the sense that I know how difficult it was for them to come and speak.
他们来支持彼此，也来分享他们的故事。那是爆满的。我想那个法庭上甚至没有座位，整个过程持续了大约八个小时。这让人动容，因为我知道他们来到这里并说出一切有多困难。
There were people in the courtroom that Brigido had never met before. He told me that seeing so many people who'd fallen for Patria's scheme in one place, it helped take away some of the shame and embarrassment about what had happened. Patria sat at a table in front of them wearing a blue jumpsuit and looking down at the ground. The judge asked her if she wanted to give a statement. She stood up. She asked for forgiveness from the court and her family.
法庭里有一些布里吉多以前从未见过的人。他告诉我，看到这么多落入帕特里亚圈套的人聚在一起，这有助于消除一些关于发生的事情的羞耻感和尴尬感。帕特里亚穿着蓝色连体服坐在他们面前的桌边，低头看着地面。法官问她是否要发表声明。她站了起来。她请求法庭和她的家人原谅。
But when it became clear that she wasn't going to ask forgiveness from all the victims sitting right behind her, her lawyer jumped in and cut her off. The judge sentenced Patria to six and a half years. The daughters were later sentenced to almost three years. Brigido and Walter wished they'd all gotten more.
但当情况变得很明显她不会请求坐在她身后的所有受害者原谅时，她的律师跳出来打断了她。法官判处帕特里亚六年半监禁。她的女儿们后来也被判处近三年。布里吉多和沃尔特希望她们都能被判得更重。
I asked the brothers and Nubi, if Patria's crime had happened to them today, would they still work with ICE. They said they'd think twice about it, but yeah, they'd do it again. They're not so sure how many others would come forward, though. Here's Brigido.
我问兄弟俩和努比，如果帕特里亚的罪行发生在今天，他们还会和ICE合作吗？他们说他们会三思，但是的，他们还是会这样做。不过，他们不确定会有多少其他人站出来。这是布里吉多。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
If it were today, it would be difficult, because people wouldn't have the same degree of trust they had before. It's a different point in time, and things don't seem the same, don't look the same, as years ago.
如果是今天，那会很难，因为人们不会有以前那样的信任度。这是不同的时间点，事情看起来不再像几年前那样了。
This is a point top agents in Rice's division, Homeland Security Investigations, is making today, too. Last month, around the same time protests over the Trump administration's zero tolerance policy at the border erupted around the country, the head of 19 different regional offices from HSI sent a letter to Kirstjen Nielsen, the Secretary of Homeland Security. They basically asked for a divorce from ICE. They don't want to be associated with deportations anymore. It's making it too hard for them to do their jobs.
这正是赖斯部门的顶级特工——国土安全调查处——今天也在表达的观点。上个月，就在关于特朗普政府边境“零容忍”政策的抗议活动在全国爆发的同时，HSI 19个不同区域办公室的负责人给国土安全部长克里斯汀·尼尔森（Kirstjen Nielsen）写了一封信。他们基本上要求与ICE离婚。他们不想再与驱逐行动联系在一起了。这使得他们很难开展工作。
They wrote, quote, "the perception of HSI's investigative independence is unnecessarily impacted by the political nature of ERO's civil immigration enforcement." ERO is enforcement and removal operations. Many jurisdictions continue to refuse to work with HSI because of a perceived linkage to the politics of civil immigration.
他们写道，引用：“HSI调查独立性的感知受到ERO民事移民执法政治性质的不必要影响。”ERO是“执法和遣返行动”。许多司法管辖区继续拒绝与HSI合作，因为由于与民事移民政治的关联感知。
When this case ended, everyone had to revert back to their original roles. Rice, after all, was an ICE agent. He says it's not really appropriate for him to socialize with anyone who's undocumented outside of an investigation.
当这个案子结束时，每个人都必须回到他们原来的角色。毕竟，赖斯是一名ICE探员。他说，在调查之外与任何无证件者交往对他来说并不合适。
To be honest with you, I was a little sad. It was a big part of my life for a long time, and it's now over. I got used to constant back and forth to Worcester. As time evolved, we joked around. They made fun of me. They teased me. I teased them. It really was a friendship, you know. They opened up their heart, their lives to me, and who am I, I'm just a government hack.
老实说，我很伤感。在很长一段时间里，这是我生活的重要部分，现在结束了。我已经习惯了不停地往返伍斯特。随着时间推移，我们开玩笑。他们取笑我。我取笑他们。这确实是友谊，你知道。他们向我敞开心扉、生活，而我是谁？我只是个政府跑腿的。
And how would you describe your relationship with Brigido and Walter?
你如何描述你和布里吉多与沃尔特的关系？
I love them both. I mean, two great guys, and I can never thank them enough. And I really hope to God that at some point, they legalize their status so we can continue a relationship. And that's my hope.
我爱他们俩。我的意思是，两个伟大的人，我永远感激不尽。我真的希望上帝在某个时候能让他们合法化身份，这样我们就能继续保持关系。这就是我的希望。
Again, here's Walter. He and most of the others went back to living under the radar. He got choked up talking about Rice.
再一次，这是沃尔特。他和大多数其他人回到雷达之下生活。谈到赖斯时，他哽咽了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I consider him a great friend. When we bid each other farewell in the courtroom--
我认为他是很好的朋友。当我们在法庭上向彼此告别时——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
He said, I'm really happy to have known you and to meet people like you. And it fills me with sadness to know that there are evil people who do things like these things to you. And there have been times when I've wanted to call Agent Rice, but I haven't, because I'm waiting for the results.
他说，我真的很高兴认识你们，见到像你们这样的人。得知有恶人对你们做这种事，我感到很难过。有几次我想打给赖斯探员，但我没打，因为我在等结果。
He means the result of a special visa he's applying for. Walter and Brigido and their wives, and Nubi also, they may actually get the thing they were hoping for when they first met Patria. They've applied for a U visa. It's for people who help law enforcement investigate certain qualifying crimes. If they get it, it could lead to a green card. But there's no guarantees. There's a huge backlog of people trying to get U visas. The process takes years, and things feel pretty precarious these days. In fact, at the end of last month, a policy memo was issued saying that if the government decides to turn down their applications, or even find things it considers mistakes, it can start deportation proceedings against them.
他指的是他正在申请的一种特殊签证的结果。沃尔特和布里吉多以及他们的妻子，还有努比，他们可能真的会得到他们初次见面时所希望的东西。他们申请了U签证。它是为那些帮助执法部门调查某些合格罪行的人准备的。如果他们拿到了，可能会导致绿卡。但没有保证。有大量的人试图获得U签证。这个过程需要几年，而且现在这些日子感觉相当不稳定。事实上，上个月底，发布了一份政策备忘录，称如果政府决定拒绝他们的申请，甚至发现它认为的错误，就可以对他们启动驱逐程序。
Miki Meek is one of the producers of our show.
米基·米克是我们节目的制作人之一。
Our program was produced today by Diane Wu. People who helped make our show today, Elna Baker, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Neil Drumming, Damien Grave, Michelle Harris, David Kestenbaum, Adam Martin, Miki Meek, Catherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Louis Sullivan, Chritopher Swetala, and Matt Tierney. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our managing editor is Susan Burton. Editing help from Julia Preston. Special thanks to our interpreters, Daniel Scherr and Catalina Maria Johnson.
我们今天的节目由黛安·吴（Diane Wu）制作。今天帮助制作节目的还有：埃尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）、佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、惠特尼·丹格菲尔德（Whitney Dangerfield）、尼尔·德拉明（Neil Drumming）、达米恩·格雷夫（Damien Grave）、米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）、亚当·马丁（Adam Martin）、米基·米克、凯瑟琳·瑞·蒙多（Catherine Rae Mondo）、斯托·纳尔逊（Stowe Nelson）、纳迪亚·雷曼、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、路易斯·沙利文（Louis Sullivan）、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Chritopher Swetala）和马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）。我们的高级制作人是布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）。我们的管理编辑是苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）。朱莉娅·普雷斯顿（Julia Preston）提供了编辑协助。特别感谢我们的口译员丹尼尔·谢尔（Daniel Scherr）和卡塔琳娜·玛丽亚·约翰逊（Catalina Maria Johnson）。
To Cheryl David, Vice News Tonight, Kasia Cieplak-Mayr von Baldegg, Ashley Kenney, Jeff Goldberg, Jennifer Cameron, Matthew Blaisdell, Annie Schaufele, Ayuda, and Virginia Lora. This is the last week that we're working with Alvin Melathe. He has done such a great job here at so many things. Alvin, I will say, we will always have Lancaster. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia You know, whenever he and I get Chinese food, when it arrives at the table, he gets so excited, and always says the same thing.
致谢：Vice News Tonight的谢丽尔·大卫（Cheryl David）、卡西亚·切普拉克-梅尔·冯·巴尔德格（Kasia Cieplak-Mayr von Baldegg）、阿什利·肯尼（Ashley Kenney）、杰夫·戈德堡（Jeff Goldberg）、詹妮弗·卡梅伦（Jennifer Cameron）、马修·布莱斯戴尔（Matthew Blaisdell）、安妮·肖费尔（Annie Schaufele）、Ayuda组织，以及弗吉尼亚·洛拉（Virginia Lora）。这是我们与阿尔文·梅拉特（Alvin Melathe）共事的最后一周。他在这里做了很多伟大的工作。阿尔文，我会说，我们永远拥有兰卡斯特。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）传送到公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，每当我和他去吃中餐，当它送到桌上时，他总是非常兴奋，并且总是说同样的一句话。
Hello, rice.
你好，米饭（Hello, rice）。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周会有更多《美国生活》的故事。